[Music]
hey guys it's me jasmine i love potatoes
i love crispy potatoes lately i've been
seeing a lot of potato recipes on tick
tock and today i've gathered a few of
them and instead of deep frying them or
baking them we are going to test them
in an air fryer i'm looking for that
same exact crisp so if it's not crispy
it's not going to get my stamp of
approval let's do this so we are going
to start with the potato stacks and to
make these potato stacks you'll need
four yukon gold potatoes and seasonings
of your choice but i have half a cup of
butter two tablespoons of fresh thyme
half a cup of a parmesan white cheddar
blend
garlic powder black pepper and sea salt
i've washed my potatoes already and
we're gonna use a mandolin to get these
super thin slices i'm really careful
with these now because last year i cut
the tip off my index finger
with this guy
and so
use your guard use your guard i'm just
cutting them in half for now i feel like
this makes it easier to handle i have it
on the setting where it's slicing an 8
inch chip what am i saying i put it on
the 1 8 inch setting
these potatoes are looking a bit moist
so i've taken out a cloth i'm just going
to let the slices rest on the cloth to
help drain that extra moisture
now that i have all my slices i'm just
going to pat them dry
it'll help speed up that crisping
process let's now go ahead and transfer
them into this bowl and now i'm gonna
add in half a cup of melted butter half
a cup of a parmesan white cheddar blend
two tablespoons of finely minced thyme
garlic powder to taste which means a lot
it's not enough yeah
i'm gonna add some salt
and some pepper
now we're just gonna mix that up until
it's well coated oh it smells so good
already oh my goodness we got all our
potato slices well coated now it smells
like garlic heaven right now and we're
just going to stack them i don't know
how many slices to put in a single stack
but i would like them nice and tall now
that i have all my potato stacks i am
going to start putting them in the
airfryer because i'm not using those
muffin tins i'm scared that they're
gonna just fall apart so i have these
skewers they're about three inches i
soak them in water overnight to help
prevent them from burning and so i'm
just going to stick them right through
the center there
because the skewer compressed it just a
little bit i'm taking my fork and
inserting just a little bit of space so
it can promote that crispiness while
it's in the airfryer and now we can go
ahead and transfer them into the
airfryer
just gonna top it off with a little more
salt and some pepper
let's set the airfryer for 350 at
let's do 20 minutes and check it halfway
through
now we wait
yay all right the potatoes are done
these look so
beautiful oh babe do you want to come
try potatoes our potato sacks are done
they look absolutely beautiful with the
golden crispy crust on the edges topped
with some parsley i have my boyfriend
here to taste test with me how do you
think they look uh they definitely look
restaurant quality
and i just can't wait to try it actually
yeah okay
cheers
the edges are super super crispy the
inside is on the softer side i like the
contrast i wouldn't say it's like the
crispiest of potatoes but this is
delicious yeah i really like it because
it's crispy on the outside nice and
gooey on the inside kind of like a
potato wedge oh yeah all right next
potato recipe this next potato recipe is
the potato accordion i have three
potatoes right here i've already gone
ahead and removed the skin so i'm gonna
take one of these potatoes and cut the
ends off either side
and then cut it into a workable
rectangle i'm gonna do with my other two
potatoes next i'm gonna take a pair of
chopsticks and line them up on the long
side of the potato and we're gonna make
thin
vertical cuts
along our
potato block
be very careful
if you are doing this to not cut
yourself
now we're going to flip it over
and do the same thing except diagonal
cuts this time and so the chopsticks are
here in place
so that we don't cut fully through the
potato
so we can achieve that accordion
and once you do that you get your potato
accordion wow that looks so good
now that i have all my potato accordions
i am going to just drizzle a little bit
of olive oil
making sure to get it in between each
layer and then topping it with some sea
salt i'm going to get it on both sides
i have all my potato accordions and now
i'm going to take another skewer once
again soaked in water overnight to
prevent burning in the air fryer i'm
just going to fan this out a little bit
and work my skewer in i'm going to get
those the air pockets in between each
layer
to
get extra
crisp what helps me is pulling it as it
goes and twisting the skewer that way
you don't break the layers now that i
have all my potato accordions ready
we're going to throw it in the airfryer
i'm just actually going to put it on the
fries setting that's 380 for 25 minutes
i'm just gonna lower that
time to 15 minutes and we'll check on it
about halfway through while this is
cooking in the air fryer let's go ahead
and make the sauce to make the sauce we
are going to combine mayonnaise
oyster sauce
ground black pepper
and some fresh parsley
we're just gonna mix that until it's
well combined and put it to the side so
about halfway through there looking
pretty good i'm just gonna flip them
i'm thinking right now it might need
some extra time times the chicken the
potato accordions are done they look
really delicious but i'm gonna do a fork
test really quickly to see how crispy it
sounds
let's give it a try
babe another potato all right so these
are potato accordions i also have this
sauce cheers cheers
mmm
if i'm completely honest it's pretty
much just like the potato stacks but
this time in a rectangle shape so far
would you say you like the potato
accordions more or the potato stacks
definitely the potato stacks because i
like a nice crispy outside with a nice
wet juicy inside
but i feel like you're the opposite you
like a nice hard dry crispy fry yeah the
bottom of the french fry bag that's like
the place i want to be at with all the
crumbs and the fried crispy goodness oh
i love that basically a potato chip
okay next potato recipe all right we're
on to our last potato recipe of the day
and these ones are the smashed roasted
potatoes they're supposed to have a
crispy exterior and a soft fluffy
interior i'm super excited to try them
because honestly i think roasted
potatoes are pretty boring so if this
changes the game for me then this one's
definitely a winner we're going to start
off with some
small potatoes that are already washed
and cleaned i'm going to add some salt
and water
we're just gonna boil this until they
are fork tender our potatoes are now
fork tender i'm gonna transfer them into
a bowl i'm gonna toss in some olive oil
salt black pepper onion powder
garlic powder thyme and we're just gonna
toss that up
now we're gonna put the potatoes onto
this cutting board here let's spread
them apart just a little bit as we
prepare to
smash these smell amazing already i have
my glass here now we're gonna take this
and use the bottom of it to smash it to
about half an inch thick
this is very addicting it feels like i'm
popping pores now let's put them in the
fryer
and let's put it in at 380 for 25
minutes
the smash roasted potatoes are done i
did flip them halfway through they look
beautifully golden on the outside nice
and crispy do you hear that
i'm very excited to eat these let's give
them a try hey babe we got one more
potato do you want to try this one yeah
these are the smashed roasted potatoes
those potato skins are so crispy
[Music]
of the three
the potato stacks
the potato accordion and the smashed
roasted potatoes which one would you say
is your favorite potato stacks really
that might have to do with the flavoring
but i just felt like it was
so much moisture and like perfectly
crispy what was your favorite
i think my favorite this is really hard
for me because i am
that person that likes super super
crispy potatoes from the inside out
but this one is inside soft outside
crispy i'm not gonna lie i think these
ones are my favorite and i think these
were so easy to prepare like i didn't
need too many extra utensils or so many
bowls or like skewers i could wake up
and make this that's great because i
could wake up and eat this
taking convenience taste and texture
into consideration
smash roasted potatoes are for me
honestly i think roasted potatoes are
pretty boring all right guys those are
the popular potato tiktok recipes i had
for today if you have tried any of these
or will try any of these make sure to
snap a picture and tag me on instagram
so i can see
bye oh yes
[Music]
[Music]
you